sie wollen gute designer und gute
menschen sein die industrial design
studenten der fachhochschule
nordwestschweiz
an der abschlussfeier in basel zeigen
sie ihre werke und das kreativität
verantwortung heißt dass papa next
mantra gehöre heute zur identität der
jungdesigner produzentin rita ernst
gerade diese generation entdecke victor
papanek wieder für sich mit ihrer
radikaler haltige promi-team witz wie in
der kritik geübt haben fällt vom design
ist attraktiv konsumgesellschaft für den
engpass und trolle und design an der
konsumgesellschaft die jungs mit
kritische in der frage dies zeigen die
diplom arbeiten etwa das projekt stuhl
oder tisch in handwerksbetrieben von
flüchtlingen und asylsuchenden herstellt
sie sollen von den jungen designern
schützenhilfe beim einstieg in den
arbeitsmarkt bekommen
[Musik]
eine sitzbank aus gras verstärkten
thermoplast grund polster füllung aus
recycelten pet und dieses möbel wird
zunächst unspektakulär soll aber trost
spenden für menschen im hospiz mit
gegenständen und fotos verziert
gestaltetes den raum der sterbenden
persönlicher für das design gab seinem
kreis auch dies ein denkansatz papa nix
denke das sollte eigentlich draußen vor
die sein sie außerhalb der hochschule
mehren sich schweizer design projekte
mit diesem ansatz die mode aus müll aus
weggeworfenen kreierter walliser kevin
germany international gefragte kleider
wenn öko so aussieht dann tragen sogar
stars wie abfall zur show nicht
glamourös aber existenziellen für über
zwei milliarden menschen ohne wc das
mobile sanitär system muss an eine
toilette ohne wasser strom und
chemikalien
sie verbessert die lebensbedingungen der
ärmsten und geht nun in guatemala
erstmals in serienproduktion
auch die industrie denkt langsam um
selbst die von papa nick verhassten
autohersteller volvo will ab 2025 ein
viertel des kunststoffes in neuwagen mit
plastikabfällen aus dem ozean
produzieren möglich durch die
technologie der schweizer firma bekommt
und sogar das ist papanek
ein verschlossener ton behälter mit 10
[Musik]
in der schweiz landen rund 500.000
tonnen organischer abfall jährlichen der
mülltonne
sie sollen das problem beseitigen die
würmer alias die abfall recycler erst
sich eine idealistische hintergrund dass
also für mich schwierig zu beobachten
wie alles so weg gehört wird und obwohl
sie also gute und einfache lösungen im
kreis laufen im komposthaufen für
zuhause wandeln die würmer den abfall um
das stinkt nicht und das ergebnis ist
organischer dünger aber wärmer als
haustiere zwecks verbesserung der welt
die geschäftsführer von warm up wissen
das klappt nur wenn die verpackung steht
vom ersten prototypen aus plastik
entwickelte sich das design zum behälter
aus ton der auch in die lippestadt
wohnung passt durch die ästhetik dass
man es gut auch in die küche stellen
kann und wohnzimmer kommt es so raus aus
der aus der schmuddelecke und wir wollen
wohl kompostierung sexy machen sodass
jeder halte lust und freude hat seine
abfälle selber zu recyceln offenbar ein
bedürfnis das startup wächst seit 2016
stetig und wurde gerade an der london
design messe gezeigt jetzt gilts ernst
werden die jungdesigner mit der halt ist
die klubs ihre visionen von sinnvollen
design ebenfalls im arbeitsmarkt
umsetzen können
das scheitern an der realität sei
teilweise unvermeidbar somit ernst
industrie und mit konsumierende
kommissions versuche das ökologische und
soziale handeln
die nachwuchsdesigner selbst bleiben
positiv
ihr ziel in der arbeitswelt und das
system so viel optimismus und
enthusiasmus für verantwortungsbewusstes
design
papanek wurde sich wohl freuen